sound my great pleasure to introduce
Bertrand Obama who has been selected by
her class to represent them today but
he's graduating today with a Bachelor of
Science degree in biological sciences
she's a recipient of one of only five
Gilman fellowships awarding nationally
to a graduating senior by the Howard
Hughes Medical Institute the fellowship
provides full funding for five years of
study toward the PhD but he will be
entering Stanford University this fall
Betty
thank you dr. Cohen and the special
thanks to my family and the members of
the department of biology
when I think about the Carnegie Mellon
experience and it's transformative
effect a quote that I heard at a woman
in science meeting comes to mind lift as
we climb I feel that there is so much
meaning in these four simple words who
are the people who have shaped your
experiences over the past four years
here how have we or can we serve in that
role for others lift as we climb I feel
that this quote expresses the commitment
to continual learning and growing as a
person scholar and citizen that is core
to the Carnegie Mellon ethos while also
highlighting the responsibility we then
have to help this others along their own
climb that's what Carnegie Mellon is all
about using our talents and the talents
of others to build with each other and
grow the success we have all achieved at
this university has been a result of the
supportive environment we have evolved
in our talented diverse group of peers
and the powerful education we receive
here the holistic experience has indeed
contributed to our climb climbing isn't
an easy task at times it can be very
difficult it requires focus strength
endurance team work skill and
determination many times we may have
been tempted
it to give up this is something that I
can attest to adjusting to the rigor of
the work here in my first year was very
difficult and I found myself struggling
during this time I began questioning my
abilities as a student and whether I
really belonged here sometimes I felt
like I was hanging on by my fingertips
but every time I felt like I was going
to slip there was always someone there
pulling me up and encouraging me to keep
climbing the agility and balance
required to climb can be cumbersome and
luckily we do not have to face it alone
think back to the biggest challenge
you've had during your time here what
was your mountain what kept you going
the support of our parents faculty
advisers see mark coaches staff peers
and other mentors have been an essential
component of our ascent many have gone
beyond their standard roles to become
personally invested in our success they
have lifted us as we climbed using their
skills and talents to help us become
better creators that are thinkers better
problem solvers better people while
trying to discover our individual voices
and harness our specific talents we have
often been a catalyst for each other my
peers at Carnegie Mellon are some of the
most extraordinary
well I have ever met we have learned
valuable lessons about ourselves and
personally grown due to our interactions
whether it was pulling an all-nighter
for an exam or project gathering at five
are four dollar drinks
or participating in booth and buggy
during carnival we form bonds and shared
experiences that are lifelong unique and
timeless many will attest that Carnegie
Mellon is a very challenging academic
environment and unfortunately most of us
are unclear about the benefits and the
true power of the education we receive
here until after we leave when I did
research at another institution this
past summer with students from top
schools all over the country I was
fortunate to have the opportunity to
gain perspective and appreciate all that
Carnegie Mellon is and does looking back
from the outside gave me an early
glimpse of how people view Carnegie
Mellon and its students the recognition
and respect for the distinctive
preparation we receive is immense when
we're rushing through the cut to get to
class on time spending sleepless hours
in hunt library figuring out the next
scientific breakthrough in mellon
institute convening in the ce mark
office staying up all night in the
cluster working on a programming
assignment spending countless nights in
print out at rehearsal
or heading to the field for practice we
often forget the significance of what we
are doing here the magnitude of the
educational experience has given us the
ability to make an impact not only
within our fields of study but also
across disciplinary boundaries and into
societal context as we are here
surrounded by the many people who have
shared our climb over the last few years
use this time to reflect on the past
pause long enough to celebrate in the
present but get ready to step into the
future how will we continue to pursue
the dreams within our reach while being
committed to helping others do so as
well what will your own legacy be and
how do you plan on achieving it I
challenge us to keep climbing but it's
not just about reaching the highest
summit it's about bringing people with
us it's not just about improving our
rank it's about always trying to work
harder and be better by advancing the
envelope of knowledge service and
community lift as you climb thank you
you